[Music]
[Music]
yo
yo yo what's going on sleepy cognito
on a weird sleep schedule hope y'all can
hear me
let me know if the mics is good and
everything i am going to
go about finding out where my team is
i see you on the chat already that's
love being a roast what's going on let
me know if you christopher hall
i know you here what's going on let me
know if my love was
good how we sounding how we look at all
sam what's up brother
what's going on appreciate you empty
emperor
sarugi what's going on scrub nurse yeah
king should be pulling up
i know i spoke to him indie gamer what's
going on bro what's up man
shane tomlin i can't hear you at all cry
thank you shane thank you regulating my
doom
what's going on baby cause that's my guy
right there didn't narrow primero the
number one
artist out there you know get your work
done from danielle pereira you know if
y'all need
good artwork he's a good guy very prompt
very professional
you know what i'm saying forte what's up
brother reign that three yeah really
yeah dude they was looking for you
yesterday yeah
forte you know you welcome if anything
you know say dr frank sony baby oh yeah
yeah yeah you already know what time it
is
sinister you cannot throw shade at
playstation it's not allowed right now
this is a
sony playstation nation show we're gonna
have some fun
but i'll probably mute in a second
because you know king coming with music
and you know how we get them copyright
strikes
[Music]
so we can't have that but at least y'all
can hear me i'm gonna see if i can find
attic indy man what's going on bro i'm
chilling bro you got the
you got the biz going is that the biz
going or is that just chess
but uh we're gonna see what's up with
attic i think adam he may make it he's
at work
shroom kingdom what's up and um
saab might not so it might be a little
skeleton crew
you know just me and the king's chilling
talking our talk
twitch kevin os x what's going on so
twitch is in the building that's good
the restream is kicking so for y'all all
right so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
wait for the king on mute
see whoever might else want to jump join
in
and uh talk to y'all in a minute all
right let's find us what's up now
see you later
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we have 50 body time
thank you what is the future no no that
was oh
that was designer
we was live oh yeah you what's funny is
for the
second i was unlocked unmuted that's
when you pulled up
oh man what's going on yeah jonathan me
what's going on man
[Music]
these dudes have some secret sauce you
better show that sauce
okay better because if they don't
they bout to get roasted
you already see what type of time the
king is on you know what type of time it
is
[Music]
it i don't know where to go i don't know
in the bushes but i'm here
it'll be lit yo i'm gonna tell you right
now the game pass
oh oh it's crazy right now
game passes on one little cat daddy said
he here for all the penny
that's right your cat get your patty out
lay it on the table paul
mostly martinez what's going on he said
we just need some attic assad workout
i actually started working out like i've
been getting him right man getting the
water some water
you know what i'm saying putting the
shoulder down you know what i'm saying
sorry he chilling man
man barry he's chilling he ain't trying
to impress nobody yeah y'all see you'll
see this i'm drinking my beet juice
right now
i'm not endorsing them so you're going
to
see the side of it
really cut me a check yeah
[Music]
you know what it is i took that beet
juice because they're gonna catch these
beets
oh this is like we're here for the smoke
i want to see next
day if it does say
it doesn't say nothing
let's say smoke will be given
focus on third party remember remember
focus on third party true we had that
same information
yeah we didn't we we didn't take those
hands lightly so hands will be given but
for the last time we handed out smoke
we won't smoke back so we're to smoke it
you see my man phil yesterday
shout out to my man phil dominus max
with spencer's soon to be a realist
but that's samsung oh that's crazy
that's great
like that on sunday for sure ps5 game
updates on third party and indie titles
you
last saw on joe's ps5 are you showing us
our old stuff
you ain't got nothing new you ain't got
nothing
i think we get like a surprise that's
what i get
let this show be fine because we know we
gonna hear it oh you
call your favorite ps dude to get in
here because your man christopher hart
needs support
oh we got his medical alert brace a
little cause oh
i got
let me see if i can hear it on my end
cause i'll be turning it off
[Music]
all right oh oh we got the old logo son
i mean that's the system right there
look at that that's what hap oh let's
get it let's get it they're going right
into a straight business
[Music]
hey everyone i'm lou studdard producer
at toys for bob and i'm here to talk to
you about crash bandicoot 4. it's about
time
crash 4 is a direct sequel to crash
bandicoot warped the devious villains
neocortex and dr
entropy have finally escaped their
interdimensional prison leaving an
evil scientist-sized hole in the
universe now they've got their eyes set
on not only simply conquering this
dimension
but all dimensions and it's up to crash
and coco to save the day
crash bandicoot is the first totally new
game in the crash bandicoot series in
over a decade so for us at toys for bob
we felt that it was important to
reintroduce long-time fans
as well as new players to this amazing
franchise
and perspective shifting platforming
that we all fell in love with
and then we wanted to introduce exciting
new elements that we can't wait to show
you today
let's start with insanity beach this is
where crash's adventure first started
and where we
our art teams wanted to take inspiration
from not just the original games but
the animated cartoons that inspired
those original games
all while also delivering bigger more
awe-inspiring dimensions to explore why
am i buying a player
you'll see wide open new vistas
there were certain moments in the game
that crash would change outfits
think crash wearing a biker jacket when
riding a motorcycle that seemed like a
natural
area for us to customize it on xbox one
loaded the game with tons of awesome
skins that you can earn
these skins are totally cosmetic and a
fun way to express yourself while
playing the game
and just to be clear there's no mtx
skins are earned by completing different
challenges
and earning gems within levels i see it
now crash four also increases
with these new masks is a must we also
can't wait to talk to you about the
fourth mask
econo but that's gonna have to wait for
another day shout out to what we can
tell you guys isn't the only character
you get to take control of your real
adventures
here you can see that you'll be taking
control of neocortex he's all about
using his blaster to
change an enemy in this passage in
addition to the
cortex we're
he hung
unfortunately for dingo fortunately for
us his adventure begins by witnessing
the construction of said beloved diner
and getting sucked into another
dimension hey i heard spider-man is
exclusive to this too
finally there's one more surprise i'm
absolutely excited to show you today
the crash bandicoot series has always
been about exciting
all right in the past
so we teamed up with our friends at
binocs to create a brand new style of
play for crashers berry fueled take on a
mirror mode
not only our perspective shifted but now
each of the dimensions are around
a new and unique art style that really
changes the look and feel of the
experience
asking you to traverse
every player especially the
completionists out there
a reason to revisit each other but it's
definitely true
[Applause]
so that's some of the new stuff that was
christian crash bandicoot 4.
shut up please bet on x experience and
time bending madness
doesn't look like an xbox show
[Music]
i turned up just a tad today's state of
play is loaded with third time let's do
it let's do it
you should put xbox at the bottom get to
play better on that
oh man see let's see
what's this
this is
oh
why are we watching old stuff i want a
new i'm going to see the future
they told you it wasn't going to be that
much
why are we in the past we out here
supporting the video what's the prices i
want the prices
the fraud alert is out everybody put
those four alerts in the chat for
the [ __ ] out january twitter thank you
take that off
the screen nobody wanted to see that
that's a whitelist okay
[Music]
let's come on all right broken glass
playstation's everywhere
is the next generation experiences this
is the next generation this is
it look at the clouds you see cloud
gaming
[Music]
they open the box their playstations
aside
then you get broken dreams
[Music]
i agree regulated with the two-hour
super chat 20 frames per second vr and a
whole lot of motion sickness yeah
[Music]
this is sleepy
[Music]
that's i'm sure that right getting horns
up there
brave thank you johnson's beach
announcement
the special anniversary edition
adventure where you manipulate time
fully painted this is what it looks like
now
it and it's even more like a living
painting with brush strokes
animating the world
[Applause]
just show the background looking
different
sound in music
so if you want to learn how videos
[Music]
hi everyone this
i'm is to share more with you today
about her throw it all in the bushes
this whole show in the bushes so far you
got a negative 20.
look good last it's a ninja chick she
looked like jinx from giant adventure
games
oh
[Music]
we need some cherry blossoms jonathan
peterson
[Music]
yo why is it just open space with
nothing
this man hating on indie games
[Music]
they got like five trees we need five
more
[Music]
i want to go to sleep y'all best
this is night time gaming
collecting crystals talk about the
eagle's ability to fly
this is it
i got better games on my playstation one
don't even talk about playstation 2.
this is looking like jumping jack flash
with textures
[Music]
we in the building yeah they went inside
though
atlas is all about finding your own way
forward so unlike most
open world games your cog is fun
to appear into the spirit world and
discover distant landmarks
it even shows you where you've been
playstation 2 graphics
oh
it went to two frames per second
[Music]
the whole screen is
down in the grass
[Music]
this has been 10 minutes
brothers playstation 2. somebody's
trying to finish the game
these are unfinished wait wait wait
why why are we not attacking the boss
from this footage
hunter and eagles will have to defeat
the cursed spirits to bring life back
to the switch day and date
[Music]
i hope you've enjoyed this co-op of the
pathless anywhere where any switch we've
only scratched the surface
there's so much more to explore and
discover thank you oh
the map is coming out next year thanks
for watching
so far this playstation effect has been
a dud
so yeah yeah you're giving it too low
playstation now
fodder attic message messi yeah
[Music]
here we go it's a real tripoli
and also brought in new players
i don't know if i could defend this one
it's not that silly
oh
even though this one ain't for me
[Laughter]
next
this is
[Music]
like this not like this
[Music]
oh
[Music]
this year well this is the worst one
second the ones for people shooting now
this ain't the worst one they had a lot
of other ones
these are the stories i wanted to expand
stop it chris oh they got ninjas
[Applause]
knowing that possibility was out there
is what's been exciting why are they
taking so long on this hot trash
in a lot of ways
[Music]
shout out for splunky
[Music]
[Music]
our style very beautiful very breath of
the wild
i'm not going to go in on this game
because we covered it
thank you sir let me know what's coming
in xbox oh look at our style
looking really cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
this is definitely not the way next time
you want to um want to get on the stream
man hit me in the gym
i gotta work before that i'll be only
getting all the stuff from packs
i know all this stuff look like it's
supposed to be on a switch
i know everything i've seen so far
[Music]
switch
we all waiting for the swift version
yeah that's the first one to do 120
frames
in the budget
[Applause]
xbox
you all know jail's getting it there i
don't care he's getting his work
i don't know if the animation's gonna
change he's gonna change the next box
yeah you know
you have the inside yeah i got the
inside scoop on that
what you have to do is get rid of tcl
though how about that
the package is ps5 yeah
yeah it is it looks just like it too oh
i feel like that machine learning come
on
decided to get you to buy
throw a little die
show a little time to get you to buy
mutations
it's time to talk bugs oh pork stacks
let's get it
this is what we're here for let's go
christopher
absolutely
you're out of a job
when i have a few yeah
baby
makes my snap look worse did you see
did you see the popping while the man
was walking for the building
[Music]
holiday does that be a launch title does
it mean
[Music]
550
this is already out
yeah they're probably showing oculus
rift um visuals
so we can't even say that it's already
gonna harm that
one one game i do got to look really
good remember
but i mean listen if you're a star wars
fan i'm not gonna front
this this is what a do it for you though
like if you want to weld
sabers and stuff like that raider
immortal anybody that's the star wars
fan anybody
like vader okay that's definitely what
it is
whatever you do stay in the light
indie game yes this is state of play now
the next year thank you indie gamer
i don't care what you're saying in the
game and this is the [ __ ] all right
they're gonna get this work
remedy all you control your control
you can control something better
they gonna release the real game what is
this
oh that looked like wait that was yo was
that awake at the end y'all
yes i don't know that's wake at the end
right
talk to me chat talk to me you look like
him yeah
oh awake at the end dlc bro
yo hey locked behind the paywall
playstation 5.
[Music]
oh this is the one with the kitty cat
[Music]
[ __ ] snacks in spain
[Music]
yes
[Music]
now you're playing with power
limited power alex bastion
[Music]
this is what we're here for this is it
this is it
this is what y'all been waiting for them
terror flops all them ssd speeds
yeah man it's what you get
[Music]
it is oh this is a game
this is the game this is it that look
like the sign of the men's
damn this is good it looks like the
men's
side right here man
in the game shout out to the men's room
sign got his budget up
[Music]
we're right about the same energy
respecting those but xbox did this oh
yeah
the xbox didn't do it like this stop
that oh no we need to not play like that
go men's room nothing like this it ain't
let's
[Music]
have you ever played game watch
now we're going to do game watch on play
let's go to stores
now let's take a look at two new games
new games are the forest shadows let's
get it
ghosts silently between the straight
coal lines of a corrupt state focus home
don't shed a tear they count russians
looking very
[Music]
authority and steel will not stop
one drop
[Music]
get the cg why are we wasting all this
time on cg
and smoking mirrors why every time they
say playstation 5 will get seen
from the day i got my carpet
because
that's the chest the chest is real
back to ceg what's this crazy
[Music]
which i thought five gameplay station
five that looks terrible
it wasn't like a video it's already ate
on pc
oh no what are they doing
this is this is the pokemon this is what
pokemon should be
yeah i heard this is huge yo this is
what pokemon should have been
it was great on pc
he said what hood i'm from god damn you
ain't given
no love damn i'm a great hype damn it
yo i thought it looked cool i'm to look
good today today went to the gameplay
today i go for it today went to the
gameplay i saw a little bit of the drops
and i'm like
yeah that king is right it was cinematic
he's definitely right i gotta give him
but i love i mean i heard this is
humongous now right here
is more this was big and then it died
and
i guess it's back again
on behalf of counter play games we are
very excited to share gameplay with you
captured on a playstation 5 deadline to
the mystical yeah this look like garbage
let's jump right into what godfall is oh
where's the ssd where's the power
where's the work
where's the graphic feature what is
going on satisfying moment to moment
and robust loot progression
you can enjoy the game at your own pace
playing alone
two additional teammates they don't got
it
godfather i'm telling you right now i'm
being in trouble this is it this is just
showcased with heroic knights
i've been
okay
fight
legendary
i waited for y'all now let's talk about
games let's sit outside the house
first our team wanted to do something
different
we wanted to combine action rpg loot
progression with third person melee
create what we think is a looter slasher
our game is therefore one part gear
driven and
one part the other one
not only do we want you to find
exquisite weapons
the smaller enemies
when you put that one big guy you can
only do four
no sound
by
there's
let's switch to the long sword
then there's the heavy attack finisher
which can be used
there are three signature moves to
multiple nearby targets
then there's spiral technique which
eviscerates all enemies
you can always block incoming
oh
and of course you can perform an r3
ground finisher on enemies
aren't you supposed to put your best
foot forward
yo how come we let this is what i'm
let's get the bombasticness this is what
i thought i was going to be
let's go who wants it let's go
we got bruticus
and then game
when his arm is down
we
we have a few more surprises coming down
the road such as details on loot
and progression and are eager to share
more with you
on our way to launch this holiday season
i want to see the numbers on this day
facebook and youtube there's some bug
snacks
playstation
i didn't even sleep today why i was
pumped you saw me
shout out to the dog so the playstation
5 games were
godfall and what's up with that
snack please do it
it was what it was y'all oh yeah baby
stoney baby nothing
needless to say king you are not
impressed one title you purchasing cut
it out
just probably saying that the main event
from xbox when you was like yo
at least 13 of them doing some copping
this joint right here with street
[ __ ]
that's a good death man definitely what
you thinking bro i just want to go to
sleep i mean
i mean that that godfall looking like
you know it should be back on like the
ps3 or the ps2
with those boss fights two enemies on
screen i mean
there's more enemies on screen on the
ps1 game i mean
wow i mean the okay the game of the show
was hitman vr
here we go okay okay hey baby i look
good yeah definitely what
was the other vr games they showed it
was that we had the star wars
star wars and that was it right all they
had was
star wars darth vader and that had only
three levels
yo shout out dj birdo says please king
do the voice for the chat
who's next oh dizzy i'll show this
what's the hope
yeah that's what i think i'm gonna be
real like i think this
they're playing chess still they know
that there's another microsoft event
they don't want to reveal their hand
fully as far as the price the release
this is going to come down to like
the way this is looking this might be
september y'all what's your thing
oh i'm just going to read that super
chat on the screen
all right said man 5 out of 10. okay
fair enough
scrub nurse 2 super chat
that five out of ten come on man let's
stop it now let's go
just be for real original stingers they
said straight up this
i don't care i don't care about what
they say is what you brought to the
table
like they didn't care about what we said
right we told them there was a third
party event
now we're gonna put up our show against
your show right now we show even right
all right so what happened you got work
this is hot barbie
there was nothing here that made me move
my wallet my wallet looked at me on the
table was like dumb dudes
money on them dude what you buying open
king
king you buying whole all it is is hope
and okay y'all hope god for was gonna
look good look what happened to y'all
your hope is in the bushes so right now
all y'all got is the old playstation 4
game and miles morales and that's what
you're holding on to
your knees is mine
was talking too much it was flapping
their gums
so hard now i was just flapping baby
shout out to mariota with the following
super chat aeon must die our style has
my curiosity but that was about it or
are all these coming to ps now yeah
that's a good question
yo cat daddy said this show is like
seeing someone without the snapchat
filter i
am done oh cat tell them cat
i'm done yes right here
the worst thing that they could do i
came in here looking to hate and they
gave me all the hate
i needed
looking for something you found
everything that you was looking for
oh my god this is great i feel so good i
feel so rejuvenated so energized
like y'all don't understand why i'm
gonna keep my boot on your neck
it's never gonna stop now so they're
free here the fact that they brought bug
snacks out like this was it
yeah they broke black snacks back out
that was kind of funny
i'm telling you right now your launch
lineup is
abysmal right now it's looking like
miles morales um
godfall there was one more that said
holiday y'all what was it what was the
other day i think it was one
that that we could we could kind of
picture
bug snack bug snacks they said holiday
right
oak snacks
that's the question if it's a
multi-player yeah if it's a multi-plat
then
it loses that you know that feel you do
think i hate just the hate right
okay for a long time i had to hear you
goofy dudes tell me
demand more you gonna see this
and you ain't gonna demand more and you
know right now they trying to dig in
your wallet
like that's a bomb in the street right
this is what i do to to individuals in
the street i'm not going to call them
bums
they're unfortunate street workers right
and when an unfortunate street worker
comes up to me and he goes
he or she goes let me get some money now
all that money that's inside my
pocket i work for right but they dance
with me
tell me a joke do something to earn this
money
right now sony ain't doing nothing to
earn any money from you
all they going off of is what you did
for them in the past
so he held the door and you remember his
face and you like yo remember me
and you hit him with another five hours
so basically what you're saying is
based on what has been shown so far for
ps5
there's nothing that is moving that
people are people are buying it
based on the hope of the bangers that
are supposed to come as opposed to
what's going on
i gotta get him with the jerry jackson
man what have you done for me lately man
def what'd you think sir it's literally
like spiderman's the seller for this
like outside of spider-man that's all
the people are interested
when they buy the ps5 i mean you're
buying it with the hope and knowledge
that you know sony's gonna eventually
give you the bangers
right then they're gonna come out sony
will it's like
let me ask you a question jeff let me
ask you a question literally
with the moves that microsoft was making
everybody laughing right here microsoft
generation only reason why microsoft uh
lost this generation because they
stubbed they told they had a goofy in
office
all right goofy not an office now
let's say y'all come out they come out
and it don't go well like it don't go
well from the jump
right like from from the initial it
don't
go well do they hold the fort do they
keep bleeding money
well to be honest with you good this is
a good question it's a good question i i
think that this is my guess the stance
seems to be
maybe right now launch the the bangers
aren't ready
for this year right so the stance seems
to be let's
par let's look at what's the best games
do like the exclusive content deals do
the marketing deals like how they doing
with avengers obviously we'll talk about
it on sunday
because kind of sim let's be real
similar to ps4 launch i remember having
ps4 outside of knack
um yeah it was in the gorilla game [ __ ]
what was this killzone shadow for
yeah yeah it was it was kind of it was
kind of weak i remember playing games
like rezo gun and stuff like that so
the vibe seems to be kind of hold the
fourth down get the exclusive stuff
miles morales is gonna sell
but i i will give you this king i don't
see anything
let's be real that's like i'm gonna tell
you this let me pay this
they sold because they were cheaper
right they sold because they was cheaper
wasn't anything else
microsoft had the games at the beginning
nobody wanted to connect they had a bad
information
in the beginning tbtv tv crap crack crap
the world was
crapping on them right now
what if they xbox is cheaper
and you lose that call of duty crowd
because that's what you got you got the
call of duty dudes you remember the deal
with call of duty is what really put
them over the top
microsoft lost that call of duty so
now they had the call of duty deal they
were a hundred dollars cheaper
they were on deck microsoft wasn't in
all the states that they were more
powerful yeah
and they were powerful so right now if
you lose power you lose price
what what do you really have to offer
like this strolling right here
and and y'all keep i know you're gonna
say yeah that's right i'm riding with
xbox yeah that's right i waved my flag
yeah that's right i got the right to do
so
but at the same time i got these paupers
that's standing out my window
telling me to give them some money right
and they're not showing me what i should
give them money for
now you pay wall spider-man on purpose
this is
looking more and more obvious because
you had nothing to show
here so it's looking more and more
obvious that spider-man definitely
had to be behind a paywall in order for
you to get 500
and you're going to get the 500 from me
so i can continue a story that i started
on the last generation
just to play it now with a little bit of
ray tracer in 4k
and then 64. and a separate disc of the
old game i believe
on the side so something to that effect
i believe no i mean
listen king king might be on to
something you know
i'm not going to say not you just look
right now i'll be honest you know
outside of me being a hardcore gamer
that gets
everything and to be honest i was
pulling for god for
because i i thought it had potential and
i don't think this showing really did it
any favors i think the frame pacing was
off
you know when it showed at the pc show
it looked impressive
so yeah you know this didn't this didn't
this wasn't good now i don't know if
it's the stream but what
it just did not look impressive i can't
even cap like it it did not
you know which leads me back down to
miles morales which leads me back
down the avengers with the spider-man
deal
but i guess my only because my concern
and i'm speaking to the chat y'all like
sony playstation as you're like what is
just based on the launch line of what is
getting y'all excited
for launch because that's the only
question i have like what am i going to
be really
outside of miles what are we really
digging into and we do know that's a
shorter experience
that's my concern will they be able to
hold the fort down and people could say
what they want about hello infinite and
rightfully so but it's a full game we
know we're getting
you know what i'm saying the 120 the
multiplayer you know all that other
stuff
and that's still going to have a base at
launch will it sell important center i'm
not going to go there i don't know
what's going to happen there
but i just want to know like what's
exciting y'all
for launch if you're a playstation fan
in the chat if y'all could put that in
there
let me know especially christopher hart
what's your which i know all of all the
sony nation in the building because
that's my thing is gran turismo seven at
launch though chris
no no it's not they didn't
we know about bangers we know about the
future but from a pure
lord yeah what are you guys excited
because that's what i'm struggling he
says ratchet and clank now if we get
confident
day one stop it i don't know if it's day
one we just got to find out man that
that's that's my concern i don't know
what
the law you know what it is
this is what i'm saying right now that's
what it is there's a lot of
misinformation
these dudes is running around believing
certain things is at launch oh that was
at the sony show so this is at launch
this is not what they come into the
store with
right this is not this is the reason why
shout out to my man hip-hop gamer shout
out to my brother hip hop gamer shout
out to my homie hip hop gamer
this is the reason why i said what i
said
when i said oh i know you put the back
right there yeah
xbox day one against playstations
day one right i know for a fact
this is this has been proven you know
except for one launch where they would
just
outrageous i think that was playstation
one
or playstation playstation two they have
madden that's man and they had
um but they didn't they don't have
a good launch lineup ever because they
go off to the street for their name
right right and then they want when when
the sale starts to dwindle
then they throw a bang out to boost the
sales back up
right and then when that starts to go
down a little bit then they throw
another
banger out and they've been the cadence
that they've been doing
my thing is you got a a a lucky
you you snuck punch dude and he fell out
you know it's like you know you hope
you're getting ready into a fight with a
dude like if i sneak them right now
i might get that one hit a quarter by
the ladder yeah
and they caught they caught him and you
know he went down and donny went out but
phil got up was like
he could have done like it yeah he
started
to dip yeah yeah we're gonna dip two in
a minute but i just wanna
get his joy i mean look you know we just
gotta see what's going on i think i
think kenya is onto something as far as
the launch lineup
i do think they may go the exclusive
deal marketing deals
i wouldn't be surprised i'll say this
here now i wouldn't be surprised if
like last of us and goes to sashimi have
some form of extra content or
boost right at ps5 launch right so this
way that can help
justify obviously they can't put that
behind them what would they think they
wouldn't
i don't care what they do they better do
it they better put it as
playstation five exclusive people i
don't care do what you're gonna do yeah
get that money
i'm gonna tell you this um listen this
weekend from the 6th to the 12th i think
it is it says or whatever the time
um there's a free play weekend i don't
know about the place i think the
playstation has a free play weekend as
well
right um but i know xbox does so
if uh you have uh game pass or you don't
have
xbox live and you haven't been able to
do that stuff just jump over
and play everything that you want to
play to show all the games just go on
your dashboard check that out
i think playstation does as well i'm
going to check all right because i don't
play on my playstation that much i'm
trying to finish this goes to sashima
but if anybody does know that y'all can
hit me with that information in the dm
and i'll definitely jump on my
playstation as well
blaze shout out the game over brian with
5 have what i've seen
have what i've seen i'll keep my tsl
blaze [ __ ] i shoulda had you in baby i
need it i needed some energy
sony is gone baby that's what blade said
blaze you like the show real quick i
need that man hit that like button
please don't put nothing in that chat
don't do it blaze i need to know if
you like the show brother i need to go
and they're gonna come for you blaze
just act like you're in here [ __ ] say a
word and just walk away from this body
on the floor
walk away get out of here cat daddy
what's your oh
hey king what's your psn and then def do
your outro bro
oh my psn is xbox 360 level 01 i'm not
trolling
oh hold on blaze 4k said mid show he
kept it a buck
macho channel what's y'all i was looking
for you macho cause genshin impact
that was the game that was impressive
get your impact was there just i was
just real quick get is genjin was
exclusive or genshin is multi-plat
i think it's multi-plat but he looked
good it looked good but shout out to you
yeah you're so messy you're so messy i'm
gonna tell you right now anything that
was over there that was multiplied
played better on the x yeah
yo shout out to patriot [ __ ] the sad
part for me is not been able to see
spiderman miles morales gameplay win the
game yeah
games called holly twenty
thanks for having me it was a very made
show and i fell asleep but shout out to
you know the chat and everyone for
tuning and you can find me on
everywhere on pc and xbox at their
singer and on twitter
no doubt oh salute to my bro macho
channel he said ganshin is on ps4 pc and
mobile yo if you wanna know about it you
know i know where to go
go to that lords of gaming.net you know
what i'm saying i could know about that
again if you was interested in that
because my man got like three articles
out there they're on fire
please look at the playstation section
if you're interested in shin it look
good i thought oh pathless i am capping
i don't care what kings say
okay i am in the only way i'm not
in is if it come to gamepad
that's when i'm out if vic find out it's
multiplied but if it's exclusive to sony
uh actually
talk to the people let them know where
they can find you oh king of the statues
is going up i i got that right down
i'm debating because kyle got a lot of
stuff going on got a lot of stuff this
weekend so i might just do it just next
week um
had to finish the statue of room in the
back that stuff was done
as you can see like everything has been
switched around um
follow me on twitter king david otw
uh like i told you before go to our
instagram
yes go to facebook go to our
tick tock iron lords podcast and lords
of gamer.net
uh also check out the last word tomorrow
with a little cognito in the contest
morning see y'all sunday also tomorrow
see me tomorrow
castle x at 9 00 pm where it's a little
red and a little blue
red starting to incite you he said look
at king surrounded by you know what he
tried to do
you know he tried to throw that dog no
he just don't trust he tried to get you
to beef with that person that you was
breathing with
anyway stop being it's not being messy
right now
regulated alpha one two i said king you
have to check out my sky base on
grounded
that's right oh y'all check it out i'll
check it out definitely
dizzy for being in the chat man send
dizzy some love man he going through a
lot right now
shout out to the shot oh yeah still
super 300 in here man this is crazy
dometic two dollars from check mario
king
talk you right there oh sh
yo yo yo i'm not coming to your house
bro why does mario keep moving around
like silent hill
i'm not feeling that bro i'm not feeling
that i'm not coming to your cribs
that's scary right there ah dog chill
chill yo he was at the other spot like a
nine
yeah something going on in your crib fam
nah nah we're not doing
this mario's wow spooky
yo you saw that philly thrill what's
going on chill
right nobody coming to kick outs dumb
statues is possessed i don't know what's
happening
nah anyway you already know incognito at
twitter yo shout out to that for pulling
up
you know what i'm saying and then the
chat is rolling yo the last word
tomorrow you know so yeah you got to
have a
movement on sunday yeah yeah i don't
move himself
yo that's crazy oh your last word should
be 9 a.m
we should have a fun guest at the
destiny community check it out also this
weekend
special special special shout out we're
gonna have a
cool thing iron harvest we're gonna be
the lords
the iron lords versus iron harvest 3v3
versus the devs should be saturday at 12
p.m eastern
check us out should be a fun show it
should be addict my boy um snowdo
and um undead undead should be in the
building so it should be three
r3 versus the devs we might get washed
but we're gonna try to put up a good
fight
and then on sunday iop should be lit we
should have
um two guests on that i don't want to
spoil just yes in case of logistics
but um that should be it man but yo
salute thank y'all for pulling up we
gonna get up out of here y'all messy
or 300 of y'all